all right so before we take a look at
clatter of scales we're gonna go ahead
and jettison this engine because we are
halfway through our PAX Prime demo and
we are going to get rid of this as a
nice little kind of screw you to the
boats in and also because it kind of
helps us to get inside this tube that
I'll get us to his command center yeah
once pickle gets to salvage what's left
over from this edge it yeah that's a
win-win
yeah and they didn't need the engine
anyway I mean this is a crashed
spaceship what the heck are they gonna
do with it yeah where they gonna go on
vacation dancers know what I mean maybe
they can barbecue or alright so pickle
is leaving us to go take care of himself
by sorry cuz we've got the skipper who's
gonna help us get to the bosun that
seems like a great time for us to take a
look at cloud shop skills yeah so clap
tracks clap transaction skill is caught
volt on TXE and we really designed it
with his personality in mind it's as you
can see it's a bit of you know it's
still a beta software and it doesn't
quite run that well on his hardware what
it's supposed to do is analyze the
situation in front of him and choose the
best kind of skill to give him to take
care of that situation it doesn't always
pick the most obviously awesome one but
they're all useful yeah so as it's going
through its to go like hey maybe this
time it should be Midna should be blight
trap in which case and we'll sort of
mimic some of the abilities that that
little of the siren had other times I
might deploy a turret like like accent
it'll be a little bitty claptrap turret
but it will pack up with huge mystery
like everywhere this tiny little cute
claptrap shooting rockets out all over
the place
but another time you might get clap in
the box which is this giant bomb that's
gonna explode no matter what and you
know this is really useful you have a
big crowd of people but you know it
could be annoying if you don't use it
right so we're gonna take a look I think
first at the fragmented frack shop tree
now fragment frack shop is probably my
favorite skill tree I I like to use when
I place claptrap because
it forces me to change weapons more
often now this one has these weapons
subroutines so you can choose to go the
assault rifle subroutine or meal a
subroutine or or shields and what it's
going to do is it's kind of cycle
through these subroutines you got this
message up on screen and whenever you
see it come up you're gonna want to
switch to that type of weapon because
you can't become a lot more powerful
using that yeah flexibility is
definitely the name of the game you
can't get too comfortable with one gun
because if the game says like shotgun
and you were using an assault rifle you
better switch over because that's where
the majority of your damage is gonna get
exactly and he cycles through elements
as well and the really cool thing about
this one the capstone actually unlocks
to an action package which claps I can
then choose from when he ran demise his
action skill and this has a laser disco
ball which shoots out elemental lasers
all of the elements in this beautiful
rainbow around and all the scabs around
him I think next we're gonna take a look
at is the I love you guys tree now this
is very much a co-op themed tree it's
it's perfect for claptrap as well
because claptrap really just wants
someone to like him so of course he has
the entire skill tree dedicated to
making it good in co-op I think one of
my favorite parts of this one is
actually the capstone court and the
capstone skill because he has this thing
called high-five guys and if you hold
down the melee button there's a normal
prop up waiting for a high-five from his
co-op buddies if he gets the high-five
everyone will get buffs and oak sees
pull a thumbs up going across the screen
if he's left hanging though he'll go
with to screw you guys mode where he
keeps all the busts for himself he's a
little big thumbs down will pop up
everywhere on his screen and the final
skill tree boom trap is all about doing
all kinds of explosive damage so you
don't need to worry about other
elemental types and the really cool
capstone for this one unlocks his
awesome pirate ship mode so he'll
actually turn into a pirate ship with
sails and in cannons and everything
through cannonballs out to the tune of
the 1812 overture which is really really
useful against flying enemies there's
definitely some really cool things in
this tree and the middle of the tree is
a thing that will happen to fight for
your life mode where he'll let out a
little minion trap that will go and blow
up or on a nearby enemy which is a great
way to get back into the fight I think
for today we're going to put
our emphasis on the I love you guys tree
that way we can show off the high-five
that's if when playing with someone that
Lysa flap Drive
who doesn't like claptrap they're out
there I've seen them what no I don't
believe you they usually hang out in
dock oldest all right and now that we
have all of ours from the skill points
use we're gonna move on with the story
yeah we're going to get inside the
engine core and hopefully go disable
that that force field that was stopping
us from getting to the military I call
before and for this for this demo we
have Nisha with us who some of you may
remember from the previous now from the
other video
Nisha is going to help us out here maybe
see some of her skills in action as well
it's alright clap job you can make the
jump yeah you did it you're at the best
clap job
alright we got a pretty massive jump
coming up yes but luckily someone left a
handy jump at that yeah jump pads are
really fun in this game
they're not just a great way for you
getting from point A to point B it's
also a great way to prime e for a slam
attack yeah because she's go so high
into the air but you'll do even more
damage because of how high you are when
you've started that's a really nice way
to just say hello to the unsuspecting
cratis gasps Oh poop deck o is gone
someone's gonna clean that mess up I
don't even think the skip is trying to
hide her intentions at this point yeah I
think that bosun's sweet as he has are
at least as sweet as scabs go hasn't
quite figured out what's going on here
but the skipper is definitely on our
site and helping us out yeah all right
let's head down and see if we see some
awesome clap job action skill nice slam
and I think we picked off poopdeck sauce
here did we which makes a very classy
talent when you do a slam boss all the
way all right what are we gonna get
okay the pocketbooks gotta get in there
alright watch hot take out that badass
Oh getting it someone what clapping a
box does is when that actually occurs he
gets this big old timey bomb at a time
with a very short fuse they have a few
seconds to find someone to detonate on
but what do you do you'll do a mass
amount of damage it's a bit of pressure
but yeah you can take out a whole crowd
if you do it right
very pro second win there from vodka
all right let's see what we get this
time in the clap stop realized gun
wizard this is gonna make everyone shoot
much faster in their reload speed much
boss it affects everyone in the party as
well I think the great thing is like
when I place pop shop I definitely
enjoyed playing up close so something
like gun wizard really helps out because
I get to you having such a high rate of
fire I'm able to unload my magazine very
quickly
yeah I DPS your accuracy does go down a
little bit but yeah if you're you're
fighting up close like that it's super
useful plug that fun jump had an action
I think our klatch I've got a little
lost but that's alright yeah he's DPS
software isn't the best that's what we
have that handy mini-map in the top
right corner for that that beautiful
Waypoint indicator will tell you where
to get up I'm so a clap chaplain how to
use things but you know I mean claptrap
is new to the vault hunting sir game
right all he usually looks for his doors
to open
yeah exactly
all right sir she'll be able to turn out
that force field in the head towards the
bosun I really like the bosun threats
you know they're they're certain
nonsensical and he's really trying to
scare us but uh you know they just don't
quite make sense earlier in the in the
demo the bosun says that he wants to rip
out your brain and step on it with shoes
made out of hasit we're just incredibly
impossible
yeah and that's coming from a game seshu
just asked us bullets science science
that's right now we got cutting with it
again let's get up boys
I think actually looks like we have our
own little bitty version of deathtrap
flying around but of course an acute
claptrap form he's gonna go on here the
fire of mine enemies for us right
I clearly inspired by the by gauge the
measurements for Portland - there's a
little bit of connections that we take
from Portland - in this but it's fun
yeah just been around see he takes
inspiration from wherever you can get it
I think claps I'm trying to get a high
five but Nisha won't have any odds give
clap japa high five
he's really trying hard yay crap and
everyone's strung go for it
and now bolts by the power of friendship
take on the super badass cab all by in
the cell you wanna throw it
beautiful badass ice chunks I think
that's about all the fun we are gonna
have today with flash shot but please
stay tuned for more Borderlands the
pre-sequel which comes out and North
America on October 14th it comes out
Toby 16th in Australia and October 17
internationally thanks bye
vite
become